wie ist es heute in münster immer noch
so wahnsinnig viel schnee dass man gar
nicht weiß wohin damit
ja im endeffekt ist es genauso der
schnee ich hab's ja auch die letzten
beiden tage immer wieder schon gesagt wo
soll er hin das ist genau das problem
der schnee hat die ganze stadt mehr oder
weniger eingepackt verhüllt und diese
schneemassen die müssen halt irgendwo
hinweg ist es nicht wie sonst das der
schneeräumer fährt und räumt zur seite
da ist kein platz mehr
und wenn das zur seite raum türmen sich
ein zwei meter hohe schneewehen auf
keiner kommt mehr vor keiner kommt mehr
zurück und ich gehe mal einen schritt
zur seite dann kann der kann man das mal
zeigen wir sind jetzt hinter mir ist
auch dieser schneeberg und dahinter ist
ein großer radlader des thw das sieht
man auch selten ein radlader mit
blaulicht und wir können jetzt mal ein
stückchen hochgehen
die haben halt den bereich hinter dem
landrat schon komplett geräumt man sieht
dass und wenn ich mir jetzt mal ungefähr
sie sehen im hintergrund bildhintergrund
menschen stehen mit warnwesten vom thw
das sind vielleicht ich würde mal tippen
ungefähr 50 meter die jetzt hier geräumt
wurden am fahrbahnrand und diese 50
meter waren bis jetzt schon und er habe
neben den großen haufen gesehen der hier
noch liegt schon sieben lkw ladungen man
wartet jetzt auch gerade wieder erneut
auf lkw wo der schnee aufgeladen werden
kann
und dann werden diese schnellladung
jetzt aus der stadt gefahren so kennt
man das aus alpen dörfern aus lawinen
gebieten aus diesen bereichen wird der
schnee hat aus der stadt gefahren
da es aber das problem nicht ganz so
groß weil da gibt es so viele straßen
ist es ein kleiner ort schafft hier ist
eine großstadt und das thw sagte mir
eben sie wollen jetzt noch massiv
einsatzkräfte nachfordern radlader
nachfordern bagger nachfordern
weil wir müssen hier mit ganz großem
gerät rein wir müssen hier mit aller
macht daran sondern sind wir noch
wochenlang beschäftigt und das bringt
keinem was denn das problem ist die
hauptstraßen sind halbwegs wieder
befahrbar aber jeder auch größere
seitenstraße ist dicht und das problem
ist wenn es jetzt dort ein notfall gibt
ein rettungswagen ein notarzt ein
feuerwehrwagen hin muss er kommt nicht
durch
er bleibt stecken es gibt zwar jeder
stadt münster auch ein zwei
allradgetriebenen fahrzeugen aber das
war's und deswegen ist die sorge auch da
dass irgendwann die rettungsdienste
nicht zu menschen kommen wo sie hin
müssen weil sie schlicht nicht
durchkommen und deswegen wird jetzt hier
mit ganz schweren gerät
ja den schneemassen zu leibe gerückt
frank gestern hat es so auch eine
familie dabei begleitet die über eine
stunde gebraucht hat um ihr auto
freizuschaufeln wie sieht es jetzt nach
dieser bitterkalten nacht aus trat man
sich in münster überhaupt noch sich ins
auto zu setzen aufs fahrrad geht es ja
schon lange nicht mehr sicher das auto
zu setzen und in die arbeit zu fahren
für die die eben nicht im home office
sind ja eigentlich nicht also eben die
straßen sind relativ ausgestorben weil
die menschen einfach wissen sie kommen
ja kaum von a nach b und das ist das
nächste problem die leute kommen ja gar
nicht vor ihrer haustür los selbst wenn
sie ihr auto wie wir es gestern gesehen
haben eine stunde frei buddeln sie
kommen ja gar nicht aus der parklücke es
ist ja alles dicht und das thw sagte mir
eben das problem ist jetzt auch was mit
dem schnee der an den rändern
aufgeschoben ist er geriet das gefriert
jetzt reiben wenn jetzt aktuell auch
minus zwölf grad die nächste nacht
zwischen -8 10 gehen und da hat sich
natürlich von diesem salz was gestreut
worden ist von der von der verein
natürlich auch so ein bisschen nasser
schnee dreckiger schwere eingemischt und
das gefriert jetzt und das wird wie eine
betonwand und sie sagten das ist genau
das große problem jetzt dass man da
teilweise gar nicht mehr durchkommen in
normalen schaufeln und deswegen genau
wie jetzt hier versucht eben das thw
diese großen schnee chancen an den
rändern weg zu machen und für die stadt
pfungstadt vom schnee zu befreien aber
wie lange das dauern wird
es ist mir ein rätsel also ich sehe das
noch nicht dass das in den nächsten 2-3
tagen wirklich funktioniert dass die
leute wieder halbwegs losfahren können
von zu hause starten können ich
befürchte das wird noch viel länger
dauern
schneechaos verkehrschaos und vor allem
nordrhein-westfalen besonders betroffen
wir haben es heute morgen gesehen fragt
wie schätzt du diese lage derzeit ein
für nrw ja wenn man das einmal revue
passieren lässt es war ja wie wir auch
wirklich vorher gesagt hier münsterland
in ostwestfalen kamen die große
schneewalze das große schneechaos wir
hatten dann im ruhrgebiet teilweise im
bergischen land und rheinland eisregen
sodann hat er sich das gestern gefühlt
ein wenig beruhigt es gab zwar immer
noch schneefälle
aber dann kamen diese erneuten viel
stärkeren eiskalten temperaturen des
rauschte mehr oder weniger gestern abend
überall in den keller mit den
temperaturen und dann reicht eben ein
wenig salz auf der straße der dann
wieder gefriert denn wir haben ja
den straßen diensten gehört es reicht
nur ungefähr bis minus fünf maximal
minus acht grad wenn man noch so dabei
mischt dass das wirklich an taut und
wenn es dann unter minus zehn grad geht
funktioniert halt nichts mehr dann taut
das eben nicht mehr dann gefriert das
erneut und genau das problem hatten wir
es hat leicht geschneit es setzt sich
wieder was auf die fahrbahn
und dann entsteht eine riesen eisfläche
wird platt gewalzt auch von den lastern
die gar nicht hätte fahren dürfen
und dann gab es gerade auf der a2 einmal
im bereich zwischen dortmund und
bergkamen das hat sich zum glück in der
nacht noch wieder aufgelöst und daneben
aber auch in bielefeld zwischen bad
oeynhausen bielefeld diese riesen
strecke wo einfach nichts mehr gegen die
räumdienste kamen nicht mehr durch
und wenn man sich dann überlegt das in
dortmund sogar ein hubschrauber über dem
stau oder über diesem chaos eingesetzt
wurde weil die rettungskräfte die
feuerwehr die polizei selber nicht mehr
durchkamen gar nicht wusste gibt es
möglicherweise in dem stau unfälle
menschen in not braucht jemand hilfe und
auf einer strecke von 50 kilometern kann
man das ja nicht mal eben ablaufen dann
wurde neben hubschrauber eingesetzt um
zu gucken sind die menschen der notlage
winkt da jemand braucht da jemand
dringend hilfe das zeigt schon ein
bisschen die dramatik und das ich
befürchte auch den nächsten tagen die
ein oder andere überraschung noch kommen
wird denn die autobahnen sind auch immer
noch von gewissen schnee salz bedeckt es
gibt immer noch matsch und ich befürchte
wenn das weiter rein für betritt ja
jetzt noch kälter dann wird sich diese
situation nicht so richtig wirklich
entspannen